hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the first
sets of issues that Cicero considers in
his fragmentary work on fate has to do
with a type of determinism that he here
associates with nature's the natures of
places and the natures that people have
that we often call using an
old-fashioned word temperament and the
idea here is that growing up or being
born or living in a certain place would
have effects upon a person that would
would in some way determine their
actions would contribute to their
destiny or their fate and that's the
location that's where they live then we
can also talk about their their body
itself certain bodies would have
tendencies towards certain kinds of
behaviors and many people even in our
own time do in fact think of matters in
this way that if you're born in this
place or if you're born with this
certain set of temperaments or we might
even talk about brain states that you
inevitably are going to do or not do
certain things you'll make certain
choices and all of that will be
determined or faded something that you
cannot do otherwise there's a sort of
necessity that comes along with them now
what is the the basic argument here
Cicero says well we do in fact observe
differences in the nature's of
localities of loci in in Latin right and
what he means by there if you look at
the examples that he's bringing up
there's Athens as a city and then
there's Thebes another city and region
to the north of Athens and they each
have their own characteristics so here
in America
we might talk about the difference
between growing up in the city or in the
countryside or in the Midwest versus
growing up in the muggy south you know
we could talk about humidity and heat
and all these sorts of influences and
what they do to people and you know if
you think about for example seasonal
affective disorder right an issue for
those of us who live in places that used
to have quite harsh winters like
Wisconsin or if you think about the
people who live in places where the Sun
doesn't shine very often who you know
have similar issues like those living in
Seattle maybe there's there's actually
something to this many people would say
so he says we see the wide difference
between natural characters of different
localities that not to arrive right
he says some areas are healthy others
unhealthy and this might be because of a
whole different set of circumstances
some of which could have to do with
weather
some of which might have to do with
parasites some of which might have to do
with all sorts of other factors as well
and once we introduce human beings into
the equation and pollution we have all
sorts of other things you could think it
also about the instances of lead
poisoning in some of our large American
cities in poor neighborhoods where
piping is still sometimes lead and lead
paint has played a role in damaging
people's brains
he doesn't have those as examples he
talks about some people being phlegmatic
and overcharged with moisture others
being parched and dried up
he says Athens has a rarefied climate
which is thought to cause a sharpness of
wit above the average in the population
so he's giving a what we call a
geographical deterministic argument for
Athenian culture whereas at Thebes the
climate is dense and so the Thebans are
stout and sturdy now there is some
geographical determinism and there is
some effect on some things again you
know think about the example of lead
which the ancients unfortunately didn't
know about and poison themselves with by
using think about the influence of lead
or other metals upon brain development
maybe there is something to this but as
Cicero points out that is at a sort of
large big-picture very high view level
of determinism it doesn't actually
determine our individual actions so as
he's going to point out the rarified air
of Athens will not enable a student to
choose between the lectures of Zeno
arcus allows and Theophrastus Zeno the
stoic arcus allows the academic skeptic
and Theophrastus the friend and follower
of Aristotle who led his school the
dense air of Thebes will not make a man
try to win a race at Nemea rather than
at Corinth when we get to the level of
individual choices or even very
important choices deciding where you're
gonna go and compete or deciding which
school you're gonna study is a choice
that determines other choices the
climate doesn't actually Fate you to do
things that way you might say well the
locality could what if the Stoics are
the only people who are available in the
library that's a function of the library
that's not so much a function of the
place and web
and climate or anything like that says
carry the distinction further can the
nature of the locality cause us to take
a walk in Pompey's porch rather than in
the campus so this is quite important
Cicero will use this example of walking
or sitting or standing for what he's
going to call voluntary motions and the
geographical or climate or whatever it's
going to be determinism if there is any
such thing doesn't actually extend down
to the level of these individual
particular actions and choices that we
make so we can say that there could be
some propensity or some conditioning
because of the locality but it's not
actually going to be determining us in
any full sense he also talks about the
condition of the heavenly bodies and he
says that those can also influence
people as well
he says the the condition of the
heavenly bodies is not going to
influence everything so you know what
sign you're born under where the planets
are any of that sort of stuff it might
determine some large scale matters but
it's not actually going to decide for
you that you will do this thing at that
time
when we get to temperaments we get to
something that's less about the
environment more about who we are as
individuals and it's very clear that
different people do in fact have if not
temperaments if not something quite so
fixed they certainly have differences
from each other
dissimilarities right and he says there
are temperaments of humans that differ
he's talking about the natures the
natures of human beings differ from each
other and he says these dissimilarities
could in fact result from different
natural and antecedent causes now those
are some technical terms that were used
by metaphysics
particularly the Stoics to talk about
the things that make things happen
causes and effects we're not going to
get into what natural and antecedent
causes are here because we'll talk about
that in a separate lecture but it is
important that he uses this term several
times antecedent causes are those which
precede right they are there and then
they help to produce some sort of effect
a natural cause would be something a bit
closer more primary cause and what are
the dissimilarities that he's talking
about he gives you some examples he says
some like sweet things others slightly
bitter things some are like sancious
other prone to anger or cruel or proud
of the others shrinkin horror from vices
of that sort of pride cruelty anger so
he says we're told in as much as there
is so wide a difference between one
nature or another what is there
surprising in the view that these points
of unlike Ness result from different
causes we can observe that people do in
fact differ from each other in ways that
are characteristic some people are more
intelligent other people are less so or
perhaps they're not less intelligent
there's just less diligent in using
their mind that are not as attentive
some people have poor impulse control
other people have much better impulse
control and we can go on and on and on
with examples what's the upshot of this
many people think that temperament
once again determines us that
temperament is fate and sistera points
out that although temperament may give
us propensity towards things it doesn't
actually mean that our Volition's and he
uses the term that we can translate as
will or a volition there quite
explicitly meaning individual things
that we will or choose and our desires
there he uses the term appetit to us so
you can also saw a petite or yearnings
for something those aren't necessarily
determined by natural and antecedent
causes simply the fact that our
temperaments or our natures are doesn't
mean that the individual things that we
actually choose to do are thereby
determined and he uses as examples I
mentioned before sitting or walking if I
choose to walk to work rather than
taking my car to work or finding a bus
route to get there that's my choice and
my temperament although it may have
guided me towards one thing if I'm
self-reliant perhaps I'm you know guided
towards walking but I could still choose
to drive my car if I'm kind of more you
know lazy or lacks a day's occult
perhaps I'd rather take a car or take
the bus those things are not determined
in any way by these natural and
antecedent causes that cause the
temperament they could have other causes
mixed in there but the argument that's
being made by the people that rely on
this is that our natures are in some way
fixed by these natural and antecedent
causes and those nature's cause our
individual actions not only can we look
at individual examples of actions we can
also look at examples of particularly
important individuals who had a certain
nature but actually chose to go against
it so he gives us this great story about
the Megerian philosopher still po the
megarians were very interested in
dialectic they are a minor Socratic
school founded by you CLE days at Megara
and then still po is one of their main
representatives at this time he tells us
the Megerian philosopher was undoubtedly
a clever person and highly esteemed in
his day he was described in the writings
of his own associates as having been
fond of liquor and women but they do not
record this as a reproach but rather to
add to his rent
mutation now why would they be saying
that it's a great thing that still po
was so attracted to liquor and women
they said we would normally say well
that's those are some weaknesses those
are some vices precisely because
although he had that temperament still
po made a deliberate effort not to
completely free himself of those desires
but to not follow those desires as he
goes on he says he's so completely and
mastered and suppressed his vicious
nature by study no one ever saw him the
worse for liquor or observed in him a
single trace of licentiousness now what
does this imply we have some control
through what we will what we choose how
we use our Faculty of volition we have
some control over what we do with our
characters or our temperaments the other
example that he brings up is that of
Socrates and this is a very funny case
there is a physiognomist that's a person
who looks at your your face and you know
to a lesser extent other parts of your
body and then comes to judgments about
what kind of a person you are what
character traits you will have how you
will behave what sort of actions you
will choose
so this physiognomist xot prius
professed to discover entire men's
entire characters and natures from their
body eyes face and brow what did he have
to say about Socrates the great you
might say originator of the
philosophical tradition in Athens he's
not the first philosopher of course but
he's probably the most important one he
said that Socrates was stupid and
thick-witted because he had not got
hollows in the neck above the collarbone
he would say those portions of anatomy
were blocked and stopped up and he also
added that he was addicted to women at
which Alcibiades the young man who
Socrates tried to you know counsel and
steer towards the good who was in love
with Socrates was said to have given a
loud
for now cicero goes on to say that it's
possible these defects may be due to
natural causes but there are radication
and entire removal recalling the man
himself from the serious vices to which
incline does not rest with natural
causes
but with what with will voluntas with
effort studio and with training disk a
plena in the latin so this notion that
fate takes the form of a geographical or
temperamental determinism is an idea
that Cicero is combating and he's doing
so primarily by making a distinction
between how on a high level we may in
fact have some degree of determination
but it's not you know it's not making
everything on the lower level happen
with with some sort of absolute could
not be anything other than this way
necessity at best we have propensity
Zoar inclinations or however you want to
to put the the idea the things that are
on the higher level temperament
geography they could make it more
difficult for us make it more easy for
us but it ultimately comes down to what
we choose and we have a great amount of
malleability in how we use our volition
our will our Faculty of choice to
determine ourselves
you